I'm an editor generally the idea is to
cut out all the bad put all the good
bits together you rewrite the script
quite often in the edit and you know you
you end up with the final hopefully the
the spirit of what was intended in the
first place so it's it's like another
redrafting of the story when cinema
began most editors were female because
it was such a the technical job with
working with film reel that's when it
wasn't seen as a sort of creative had a
department type role it was seen as a
craft you know more like sewing or
something like that and then as it sort
of you know had gained more respect I
guess the men came into it you know but
still it's probably there's probably a
lot more women in editing and there
would be on other technical roles like
the camera department or the sound
Department being on this Saturday you
know and all the women around here it
took me two or three hours before I
actually intellectually realized that
there was majority women on set and I
didn't notice a difference but actually
then thinking about it it's calm it's
it's it's it feels very comfortable so
you know it's and collaborative yeah the
best thing about my job is watching
dailies I love watching the pure thing
that actors do the worst thing about my
job is when you are expected to fix
everything
[Music]
you